the satirical horror movie velvet buster
explores what happens when the
pretentious world of modern art collides
with the collection of supernaturally
charged paintings from a dead artist
with a dark and horrific past
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm John and
in this video I'm explaining everything
you need to know about velvet buzz saw
the movies ending and what each of the
kills represents plus I'll be delving
into who Vettel DS really is and how his
supernatural art comes to life as you'd
expect spoilers ahead for the movie so
take care if you haven't seen it yet
with ambitious assistant Josefina
stumbles across the dark creepy art of
dead painter veteran DS her decision to
commercialize the work that the painter
wanted to destroy kicks off a series of
escalating horrific deaths as Josefina
looks at one of his portraits the ashes
of paintings at dese was burning before
he died reignite the first indication of
the supernatural forces inside his art
the eyes on this portrait also seemed to
move slightly from the center to the
side looking at Josefina is she unravels
and examines more paintings inside the
dead artists apartment those watching
eyes are a spine chilling premonition of
what's to come for many of the
characters in the movie eyes often show
up shortly before a character dies as if
they're observing and making a moral
judgment just after gallery owner adora
reveals to Josefina that she's
deliberately removing many of geeses
works in the market in order to create
scarcity and drive up the value the eyes
on a wall watch Bryson who's been tasked
with hiding the arse and who opens up a
crate removing some of the paintings
presumably to keep for himself Bryson of
course ends up dead shortly after at the
hands of some painted monkey mechanics
just before Gretchen's deadly encounter
with the sphere the blurred eyes of the
boy and girl in this portrait to come
into focus
it's as if DISA spirit is awakening in
the painting and is about to pass deadly
judgment on Gretchen for how she's
abandoned the principles of her former
position as a museum curator to make
money and deliberately gain special
access in favors for private clients
likewise the eyes in a sinister doll
open up to watch gallery owner John just
before he strangled by an installation
in his gallery and after Josephine and
ditches dam rush when he decides to go
back to his art collective there's an
especially creepy eye on the graffiti'd
war behind her look
right at her the mural comes alive
setting a spectacular trap for her as
the gallery full of graffiti art opens
up behind the wall Josefina's death
seems particularly appropriate as the
paint from the art that she so despises
melts runs towards her and then consumes
her and after she's killed we see she's
been incorporated directly into the
graffiti'd wall what's going on with
each death is that each victim ends up
becoming part of the deadly artwork
Bryson was pulled into the painting of
the monkey mechanics the sphere consumed
Gretchen's arm and her dead body was
assumed by most people to be just
another part of the art installation
remember that the archivist who was
studying deesis paintings discovered
there was blood tissue in every one of
the work she looked at she assumed the
blood belonged to dese and that seems
quite plausible because in one of the
flashbacks as a bowl full of blood and a
bloodied knife and razor next to it
and we also see a glimpse of Dee's
painting with a hand partially wrapped
in a bandage of sores and what looks
like cuts or wounds around his wrists
writer director Dan Gilroy has talked
about how one of the themes of velvet
buzzsaw is the idea that artists invest
their spirit into their art it seems as
if by literally painting his own flesh
and blood into his works this has
invested them with a supernatural spirit
while the characters in the film all
desperately trying to take advantage of
Jesus artwork and exploit his life and
everything he lived through for their
own gain what they don't realize is
Debbie Dix who plays down rich has said
if that deesis past and the violence he
lived will actually reach out and kill
you if new victims like Josephine ER and
Bryce and end up becoming part of the
art which killed them then perhaps it's
also possible that some of deesis
paintings contain blood tissue from his
previous victims
for example we learn in the movie this
as an adult distract his abusive father
tortured him and burned him alive but
what if Dee's painted parts of his
father into some of his paintings as
well now we need to talk about red aura
and the importance for tattoo velvet
buzzsaw which carries a lot of meaning
especially as it's also the movie's
title first of all it's the name of the
punk rock duo red aura formed with her
friend Pollyanna Dan Roush tells fedora
he was a fan of their early work with
the pur eventually split up what matters
though is that red aura abandoned her
original passion and anarchic roots and
decided
instead to become part of the status quo
building a career as a well known dealer
in the moneyed and powerful world of art
as she's built her status in the art
world ridore has learned how to trick
and manipulate artists buyers and rivals
alike she understands how to pick up
promising new talent like damn rich for
her gallery while simultaneously
offloading talent like peers who's no
longer productive on to her rival Dondon
ridore
also maneuvers Josefina into partnering
with her to sell the stolen dese
paintings and in the past she's
manipulated morph behind his back by
using his boyfriend for inside
information her smarts almost seemed to
get her through to the end of the film
unscathed as she realizes just how
dangerous DC's paintings really are and
empties her house of any art or images
however DC's spirit still finds a way to
enact revenge on her for stealing his
work and the velvet buzzsaw tattoo on
her neck springs to life slicing her to
death while she's in a pose which
mirrors the art previously on her
bedroom wall ultimately as ridore ax
herself said art is always dangerous and
the no death no art tattoo on her arm is
of course particularly fitting for both
her and the movie the name velvet
buzzsaw is also an interesting oxymoron
as it implies something soft and
luxurious but sharp and deadly at the
same time it applies to rad aura and how
she softly softly manipulates people
around her while also using more cutting
methods to get what she wants for
examples threats of legal action to
force Josefina into sharing ownership of
geeses art and remember that Dan rush
says he was specifically warned to be
careful of red aura the name velvet
versal also applies to the lethal threat
that has seemingly innocent piece of art
compose velvet buzzsaw is clearly a
pointed critique of the contemporary art
world and the pretentious critic morph
certainly isn't spurred the ends up dead
at the hands of hobo man the walking
talking homeless superhero that morph
was so willing to critically tear apart
at the beginning of the movie I wonder
whether the inclusion of this particular
artwork of a down-on-his-luck former
superhero is not only a comment on the
changing nature of what's popular or in
when it comes to art but also reference
to how one of the most popular genres in
current film and TV entertainment the
super here
franchise will eventually like other
genres before it fall out of the great
favorites currently in Gilroy also
appears to think that critics can be too
fast to point out faults and criticize
the work an artist may have poured their
heart and soul into there's also some
interesting commentary on whether too
much value is given to the opinion of a
critic in the film red aura says morph
is a God in their world and when he
decides to publish his negative review
of Hoberman
it kills the sale of the piece that was
brokered before the review ran more
physik Asian Lee presented a little more
positively than some of the other
characters such as when he turns down
Gretchen's proposal to feed her early
information about his reviews however he
demonstrates he's more than willing to
sacrifice any principles he may have if
it's expedient for him to do so or to
cater to his own prejudices for example
he gives a negative review to Ricky's
art show even though he liked it because
he was sleeping with Josefina at the
time and she asked him to make her
ex-boyfriend or he suffer and when Worf
discovers damn rich is sleeping with
Josefina he yells the admiration I had
for your work has completely evaporated
he's also ridiculously fussy and
snobbish complaining about cheesy
funeral music and although he warns rude
aura that DC's work is dangerous and
that she should stop selling it and box
it up and get rid of it we see that he's
kept some of it for himself and is going
to lock it away in storage presumably to
sell in the future for a huge profit
that moment is of course his ultimate
undoing because that's when he comes
face to face with hobo man we disparage
so savagely at the beginning of the film
ultimately then the characters who die
in velvet births or receive a death that
parallels how they've behaved morph is
literally torn apart by the thing which
he figuratively taught his friends
earlier and as the movies producer
Jennifer Fox says Josefina is consumed
by the graffiti art she rejected Andrew
Dora by selling out her punk roots
Bryson is killed by acting on his
primitive nature and Gretchen for
overreaching so why are some characters
not targeted by DC Supernatural
creations and survive to the end of the
movie it seems that Gilroy may view Coco
dan burisch and peers as relatively
innocent in comparison to the others and
therefore perhaps worthy of being
spurred the wrath of dese
Oh played by Natalia dire who many of
y'all know from stranger things is too
new to the art scene to have been
completely corrupted as an outsider
who's only just joining that world she's
still clear-headed enough to understand
what isn't art for example after
Gretchen bleeds to death from having her
arm sliced off by the sphere she's the
only person who can recognize that a
dead body sprawled on the floor isn't
actually a piece of art as artists
themselves John Malkovich's peers and
Debbie digs Tamra she seemed to
understand the underlying power of
deesis art peers and Amrish both become
mesmerized by Jesus paintings and this
seems to be the trigger that leads damn
rich to abandon read auras gallery and
go back to his collective much to
Josefina's disgust peers also goes back
to creating art purely for himself
making sand drawings that the tide
gradually washes away as the credits
roll interestingly enough that scene was
inspired by Dan Gilroy's own experiences
in the 1990s writing the movie Superman
live starring Nick Cage and directed by
Tim Burton when he found out the movie
was being canned after 18 months of hard
work Gilroy told II W that he went down
to the beach and thought about how
nothing he wrote was ever going to be
seen and so he might as well come down
and write words in the sand and have the
waves just wash them away but that was
also the day that Gilroy decided to
value what he creates not for how many
people see it or its commercial success
but simply for himself however you feel
about the movie velvet buzzsaw is more
than just a horror film set in the
contemporary art world it's also a
commentary about our relationship with
any art form including movies and TV but
wit buzz sauce producer Fox has said
it's about the commodification of art
and the way in which this self-selecting
group of curators and dealers is
anointing certain people ignoring other
people and creating a false economy
gilroys also said that art can't really
exist without somebody paying for it but
once art becomes monetized it loses
something and the problem when you over
monetize art is that it becomes an
object rather than something imbued with
the spirit and idea or even a soul which
is why there's that line in the movie
where Josefina says what's the point of
art if nobody sees it the film itself
suggests that it's only the artists who
realize the true value of art as both
down
and peers reject the over commoditized
art scene return to their artistic roots
this whole idea of the point of art and
who sees it is also interesting because
although velvet buzzsaw premiered at the
Utah based indie film festival Sundance
the movie is available on the global
streaming service Netflix which means a
lot more people will likely see this
film than if it were released only in
cinemas as the writer director Dan
Gilroy he has various ambitions for the
film obviously he wants people to see
and enjoy the movie but he also wants it
to spark conversations and ideas on top
of that he told Vanity Fair that he
hopes people look at art in a slightly
different way and that they realized the
artists behind it have invested their
creative soul into the work and finally
he'd like the movie to do for the art
world what jaws did for swimming in
other words when walking into a gallery
of art one should fear what might happen
after all what about all those DS
paintings would have found their way
into the hands of street vendors selling
them for five bucks apiece will dese be
okay with this as the works are in the
hands of the people now rather than in
the privileged art scene or will he move
on from taking revenge on the
hypocritical art world to judging the
everyday hypocrisy of ordinary people so
what do you think of velvet buzzsaw and
what did you take away from the movie
let me know in the comments below and if
you're new here and enjoyed this then
every week I have new movie breakdowns
so do subscribe and hit the bell to get
all my new videos until then you can tap
left for my latest horror movie video or
tap right for another video you're sure
to like thanks for watching and see you
next time you be going movie lovers